why is every gadget having an identity
crisis first phones decided they wanted
to be more like tablets and we got
tablets then tablets combined with
keyboards to give us tab tops
now laptops are more like tablets and
they are called
lap lifts and I'm not done yet ready for
it there is now a phone that wants to be
a full-fledged computer I'd call it a
phone pewter but then I would hate
myself
this is Microsoft's Lumia 950 the first
phone to run Windows 10 yes the same
software that runs on laptops and
desktops except on the smaller screen it
has a more mobile friendly interface for
now the Lumia is extremely limited as a
computer but the idea of our phones
being the only computer we need suddenly
seems a lot less crazy
the 5.2 inch Lumia 950 looks like most
smartphones until you plug in the $100
Microsoft display dock and attach all
the rest of the standard desktop pieces
hate your mouse the phone screen can
even be your trackpad scrolling works
really well and the hexa core processor
inside the phone and three gigabytes of
RAM can drive a 1080p monitor as soon as
the Windows 10 desktop pops up you can
use the Start menu in the corner the
taskbar to see open apps control tab
even lets you toggle through open apps
ah yes
apps I hope you love Microsoft Office
because that's about all you get on the
big screen for now Word Excel PowerPoint
all look and feel like they do on a
laptop and the edge browser loads
desktop sites instead of mobile ones
problem is is that too many tabs can
make it incredibly slow and chrome is a
far better desktop browser but hang on
desktop apps and even some mobile apps
don't run on the big screen apps are
also what hold back the Lumia 950 as a
phone which is a shame because the
hardware is great the battery lasts all
day it's 20 megapixel camera takes good
shots and in low-light even better than
the iPhone you know what the iPhone also
doesn't have an infrared sensor on the
front to scan your iris to log you in
without a
password it's like mission impossible
this might not even be my real face but
because the Windows Phone OS lost so
badly in the smartphone war the apps you
love so much are either missing or just
crazy out of date
that's the Lumia 950 s biggest problem
if phones are going to one day replace
our computers we're going to choose the
phones with the apps and services we
love and unfortunately for Microsoft
that's Android phones and iPhones so for
now
the smartphone stays a smartphone
actually though can this thing become a
laptop dare I say a phone top